is there a specific kind of story a
first-time screenwriter should write uh
yes and what what what that story is and
and you know it's not that cliche write
what you know because I've never written
what I quote unquote know I I write
fantastical worlds and and and and and
supernatural stories and all of that but
write what you feel and write what's in
your heart and write something that
means something to you
and you know I was a script reader for
God probably a decade and I and I was
reading seven eight scripts a week and
the rare one was the great script and
when you found that that was a very
exciting day at the office
and sometimes the really terrible
scripts were kind of they were fun
because they were so god-awful but the
ones that got really exhausting and
really innervating is a script reader
who's sitting there and asked to read a
script synopsize it write a comment
about it then pick up another one and
read it and it's not were the ones that
you could tell were written by people
who were looking at what last year's hit
was and trying to imitate it and those
were deadly and they were they weren't
good they weren't bad they were safe and
mediocre and any writer any young writer
any old writer anyone who's just
starting to write anything write
something that you feel write write
write write something that comes from
the heart and and and people may not
think that Betelgeuse is a personal
movie it's an intensely personal movie
it was intensely personal for Michael me
and and you know I I didn't know I had a
theme until I had enough work to realize
I had a theme and almost everything I've
written are about broken families who
are put back together
or in some bizarre way but there but
because I came from a broken family and
and what and and and so so that there's
a I like to think that my work has a
sense of heart in a sense of compassion
and a sense of humanity in it no matter
how bizarre it is no matter how weird
the worlds get and and you got you got
to write something that you feel on
something that you have some passion for
or just why do it it's too hard it's
just it's not an easy job and and I
personally can't imagine saying well
this was a hit now so I'm going to I'm
going to write my version and that I
don't really it's not really what I care
about what I feel but I can imitate it
well enough I can't imagine spending a
year of your life doing that but people
do it all the time and they usually
write me do Chris Krebs is being safe
something that's never appealed to you I
I don't know how in in in in my career
and in my life say safe hasn't factored
into it and and not not always not
always the best decisions maybe but I'm
just I sort of like jumping off cliffs
you